when Disney announced they were remaking
their much-loved Animated Classics
Beauty and the Beast fans wondered what
exactly the new filmmakers would keep or
change and whether the new movie could
ever reach the incredibly high bar set
by the original UPK movie lovers it's
Jan here and in this video I want to
take a look at some of the very best and
some of my least favorite changes and
differences between Disney's live-action
Beauty the Beast
and the 1991 animated movie naturally
I'll be delving deep into spoiler
territory so be aware of that if you
haven't seen the new movie yet and if
that's you you can check out my spoiler
free review of the film by tapping or
clicking here I love how they took
Belle's character from the original film
and expanded and updated it and what
felt to me like a very natural way so
Belle still a literature loving young
woman as she was in 1991 but she also
wants to pass that love and knowledge
onto other young girls in her town and
not only did she help her father with
his own craft making music boxes Mike
she did with his inventions in the
animation but she's also an inventor in
her own right
creating contraptions to make life
easier and give her more time for the
thing she enjoys like reading and
sharing her knowledge we also see Belle
firmly shutting Gaston adver house and
plotting her escape from the beasts
castle and even her clothes reflect the
fact she's an active character for
example she was boots and her skirt
hitched up on one side to make riding
her horse easier the updates to Belle's
character not only fitting given the
fact that this is a film for modern
audiences but they're also a
continuation of what began back in 1991
with Linda Woolverton
who was the first female screenwriter of
a Disney Animated Feature Wolverton
wanted Belle to be less passive more
independent and more relevant to
contemporary audiences than previous
Disney Princesses but often found it an
uphill struggle to get their ideas
through to the final film for example
the scene Wolverton wrote with Belle
marking a map with all the places she
wanted to visit was switched to show
Belle baking in the kitchen until it was
agreed that Belle would walk around
reading instead but did I love the
original animation I think the new
filmmakers made a wise decision when
they decided not to have Gaston jump the
gun and set up a surprise wedding for
Belle Gaston still super full of himself
in the new film but what we get instead
of him putting his feet up at Belle's
house and assuming she's going to marry
him is Gaston trying a Sisler but
perhaps more devious approach by
claiming to sympathize with Belle over
her mistreatment by the headmaster who
put a stop to her using her
washing machine it's still clear from
their conversation that they'd be
hopelessly mismatched as a couple and
there are several nice nods for the
scene from 1991 including Gaston
alluding to Belle having his children
and also after she rebuffs him he walks
off and steps into a muddy puddle a
callback to the animation where he lands
headfirst in a muddy pond after fowl
shows in the door Gaston has many great
moments in the animated film and Luke
Evans there's a fabulous job bringing
him to live-action life giving his
character a more grounded field in the
original by playing him so real and the
comedy so deadpan one of the many things
I love about the new movie is my arrow
cadenza and Madame de Garda rob
obviously cadenza is a new addition to
the castle characters but I love how he
fits in well with the existing
characters thanks to the fact that they
make gyda Rob his wife and make her
human counterpart an Italian opera diva
oh and making their dog frou-frou become
the footstool character from the
original movie was also a really nice
touch also their character design in the
way that carry through into human forms
is just wonderful Gardo hob especially
is a triumph of imagination in her
wardrobe form inside her doors you see
stage curtains footlights and box seats
all of which really bring through the
fact that as a human being to the
performer and also that she has a rather
dramatic theatrical personality and two
really neat details after the enchanted
cadenza has fought the angry mob by
launching his harpsichord keys at the
magista of bullets when he's turned back
into a human being at the end he's
missing many of his teeth Audra McDonald
and Stanley Tucci hue bringer devolve
and cadenza to life are just brilliant
in the film both in their own right and
together
I love how son their characters are and
love the sweet way they interact with
each other in the film I love how
various Easter eggs and hidden details
are introduced into the film through
their characters and I love the very
talented actors who play them and the
fact that their relationship as to the
movies diversity
speaking of which guard of Hobbs
character is also part of another scene
that adds another element of diversity
to the movie when in the final battle
she wraps three men in dresses to whom
run off as in the animated film while
the third is delighted to have come out
of the closet so to speak of course it's
been a lot of talk about the food being
gay in this film as well which is
character experiencing mixed feelings
for Gaston and dancing briefly with a
man during the final celebration it's
actually all very subtle and certain
me no reason to raise the rating
cutscenes or refuse to screen it which
is what's happened in some parts of the
world the films already updating the
towel for modern audiences in terms of
Belle's character making the cast more
racially diverse and excluding LGBTQ
characters from that diversity would
quite simply in my opinion be wrong one
of the lovely touches that the
filmmakers of introduced into this movie
is that as time passes and each petal
falls from the bistros we see and hear
the effects of this on the castle and
the enchanted servants so Lumiere and
Cogsworth joints start to seize up
making it harder for them to move the
duster plumet gets several new feathers
and the water of guide Avadh becomes
increasingly sleepy and lethargic to the
point where she falls asleep after only
semi finishing a crazily over-the-top
dress for Belle and on several occasions
the castle itself rumbles and creaks as
various bits collapse and fall away from
its exterior showing the castle and its
inhabitants reacting to the effects of
the spell over time is a beautiful and
subtle addition to the movies world and
it's perhaps a nod to how in the
Broadway musical The effect of the spell
on the household servant shows itself
gradually anyway I loved how it
integrated so well into the story and
design of the movie and how at the end
as the last petal Falls the servants
became inanimate and made to resume
their human forms in delightful ways for
example the DOS diplomat emerge from a
pile of feathers as the new song was
written by composer Alan Menken and
lyricist Tim Rice for the live-action
film
my favorite is evermore which the beef
things after he sets bail free to go and
help her father it's a really gorgeous
musical number full of lofts
longing and sacrifice and accident
Stevens performs it so well and days in
the zone which I already liked the first
time I saw the film really got me the
second time I watched the movie - such a
wonderfully melancholic lullaby like
songs sung by the enchanted servants
about their former lives and it's really
very moving and it's been really
interesting to see if any of the new
songs get Oscar nominations next year oh
and it's not a new song and she just
gets a few lines but I love hearing
Audra McDonald as guide of obscene
beauty in the Beast right at the end
she's got such a beautiful voice and
presence but it seems unbelievable that
years ago into your audition to be in
the ensemble for the Broadway musical of
Beauty and the Beast she didn't get the
job anyway she totally nails a song here
she's just fantastic
and add to that the new beauty the
beasts lyrics that Emma Thompson sings
as mrs. potts right at the end and it's
just perfect by the way if you want to
know more about those new lyrics and how
they came about I talked about that in
my Easter eggs video which you can click
or tap here to watch one line I'd love
in the animation that doesn't make it
into the live-action film which i think
is a real shame is Gaston you are
positively primeval which spell said in
response to Gaston comments about how
women shouldn't read as it'll give them
ideas and how she should be paying
attention to more important things than
books namely him what we get instead of
that and Belle's refusal when Gaston
invites her to look at his trophies in
the tavern is a scene where Gaston tries
to invite himself to dinner with Belle
which he turns down only making the uber
arrogant captain even more keen while I
did enjoy this new scene I still would
have loved to have heard that line from
Belle in the new film as soon as they
announced that frozen star josh gad was
going to play the food one image from
the animated film pops straight into my
mind yes it was a scene where Love Field
who's been forced by Gaston to wait for
Bela Maurice outside their house gets
covered in snow like a snowman obviously
Josh GAD character in frozen is a
snowman Olaf so I was really hoping
they'd recreate that snowman scene from
the 1991 movie even though I knew it
would be such an obvious joke and that
alone would mean they probably wouldn't
do it in the end because of the way
they've changed the story in the new
film the events that lead up to that
snowman scene in the animated movie
wouldn't make sense here but I would
still have loved to have seen Josh GAD
in live-action snowman form but despite
the fact I didn't get my snow guard in
the movie I think Josh GAD is superb in
Beauty and the Beast and works so well
with Luke Evans as Gaston one moment in
the film that didn't seem as natural or
smoothly executed as a rest to me with
one Belle meets Lumiere
in the original film Lumia introduces
himself to her before the big song and
dance number be our guest within this
film she meets him earlier when he goes
to her cell and offers to his quarter to
her room
Belle seems a bit more taken aback in
this version where she meets the
enchanted servants for the first time
but that's not my issue with the change
does it be perfectly normal for her to
be shocked to see a talking candelabra
for the first time what didn't work for
me in this new scene was the way her
reaction to him seems delayed or a bit
disjointed what I mean is that she's
already seen him
to him but she still decides to go ahead
and hit him with a stool and then after
that she screams I can see what they
were trying to do with the scene and how
they were also echoing maurices reaction
to Lumiere from the 1991 film but the
way the scenes been put together here
seems incoherent as if it wasn't
scripted or edited quite right so it
ended up not ringing true for me when I
first saw the trailer to beauty in the
Beast a good affair wasn't super keen on
the look of the enchanted objects
especially mrs. Potts I mean I just love
how expressive she looks in the animated
version and in the new version she seems
less though and on top of that of course
the animated mrs. Potts has a spout for
a nose whereas the spout on the
live-action mrs. Potts is there as a
sort of arm which may have been inspired
by her design in the Broadway musical
when I did see the full live-action film
for the first time I've got to admit
that the production design did win me
over as a rather ornate and refined
design of the objects it's well was a
mid 18th century setting they're chosen
for the film still as much as I loved
Emma Thompson's rendition of tailors all
the time I'd had take on mrs. Potts that
role was still always belonged to Angela
Lansbury for me I see Ewan McGregor as
lumia while I did enjoy his overall
performance especially the be our guest
extravaganza it does sound making had a
tough time with the French accent and
he's actually said as much himself so
again much as I love Lumiere and the new
movie as a whole it's still Jerry Orbach
animated Lumiere that wins the day for
me and I say the same for Nathan Macs
take on chip in the live action movie
versus Bradley Pierce's animated ship as
well now I'd love to hear your verdict
about the changes between the original
animation and Disney's live-action
remake what did you most enjoy and what
didn't you like let me know in the
comments below and while you here be my
guest and enjoy some of my other beauty
in the beasts videos including 17 Easter
eggs and hidden details you might have
missed in the new movie and ten movie
mistakes and plot holes from the
animation that the new movie fixed you
can toggle click here to watch any of
those and check out my full playlist
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers